ready boom welcome to the simulation my
name is tristan blake filling in for
alan sake on interviewing alan sake on
what so tricia thanks for having me well
it's it's funny you know i love these
kind of like role reversals um it's
always interesting to experience things
from two perspectives right from the
perspective of let's say an investor and
the perspective of a someone looking for
you know a start-up company right once
you do both you really get a sense for
all the sides i mean have you ever done
something like this before like where
the roles are switched yeah yeah it
rarely happens when it does happen it's
usually really profound exploration
mm-hmm ya know so you know i'm really
interested to ask a lot of questions
here i think a lot of people want to
know kind of where do when what inspired
you to create this series I mean how
many episodes has been like were 600 and
600 conversations yeah right to me
that's obsession of the the only thing
that I the the only human characteristic
that I truly like embrace and love Tim
you know measure and experience what
made you obsessed about 600 episode what
made you obsessed to do this thing to to
have all these conversations and to
bring this information and put in a lot
of work to let everybody experience it
with you kind of what motivated that I
really appreciate you wanting to
interview me and ask these questions and
hopefully it can shed some light on what
may be helpful for other people and this
a lot of this has now become about the
nature of reality why are we here why
was this made what's actually going on
how do we inspire
they're people to care about these most
first principled questions what are they
uniquely blueprinted for how can they
bring those gifts into the world talking
to all these leaders of edge of their
fields and trying to gain insight from
what they're doing and inspire other
people to get to the edge of these
fields and this is a very Polymathic
show so we feature scientists
entrepreneurs spiritual leaders people
that study blockchain and crypto AI and
robotics biotech neuro tech geopolitics
geo-economics the deepest parts of the
human psyche regarding meditation
psychedelics feelings of
interconnectedness feelings of ego death
I mean we're just so deeply all over the
place that hopefully it gives people a
deeper insight into the nature of the
reality and that's initially it started
that way a couple years ago was just
this list of really thought-provoking
questions that I sent you and many other
leaders that I knew and I sent this a
list over and it was just a lot of
responses in 2017 from people that were
like this is the best list of questions
this is your probing reality with the
most complete the best compression
algorithms of questions that can then
elicit the most interesting responses
from people and this is juxtapose with
things like you know let's talk about
the weather let's talk about sports yeah
I know that type of stuff and so when
you want to gain a better understanding
of the world that you're in you have to
formulate these complex multivariate
questions and then ask other leaders
those questions and just become
obsessive with them and that's what the
last 600 episodes has been and it's been
across different places in the world
it's not just been the United States
which has been really interesting most
recently we came back from almost three
weeks in Beijing Hangzhou Shanghai doing
interviews in China interviewing Chinese
principal investigators and leaders
there professors and it was super
fascinating because you know you're
immersed more into a completely
different culture of evolution and it's
very fascinating to hear
perspectives but it's also fascinating
to see the similarities yeah and so we
hope to you know continue going to
places like India or Saudi Arabia or
Europe South America there's all
different beautiful places to go around
the world and to and to interview their
leaders there and to show that we are
all one in this big global communion
that we're having and and and hopefully
that's what we can continue showcasing
that's there's a lot about the question
and not about the answer and getting
people awaken to the process of asking
the best questions possible I think it
takes a lot of courage to ask that
question I think a lot of people in high
school and even before that kind of
wanna talk about these things but I just
I remember myself I wasn't allowed to
talk about them it was just weird I
guess and finally like now here in
California we're able to discuss this
regularly with almost anyone you know
even in the checkout counter that's it's
kind of okay but I think in a lot of
places it's still not okay to ask
profound questions mmm and and I think
that you're actually the expressing a
lot of courage and asking on behalf of a
lot of people so it's cool I appreciate
that thank you for 600 questions were
six hundred sessions worth of questions
to these extraordinary people what are
some of the favorite interviews that you
had this is always a hard question
because they've all been so instrumental
in like shaping my worldview over time
and I hope the worldview of other people
that view the show yeah it's always hard
picking favorites yeah it's really hard
you have to choose three yeah this is
again this you know how about just the
ones that stood out a lot unexpectedly
how about that and then there's all
these things to account for like the
recency bias yeah towards like the last
couple versus the ones that happened
like episode 100 or whatever you know
it's just harder to
to remember yeah
and also over the last two years my
worldview just becoming more and more
closer to the feelings of
interconnectedness or communion with the
source that we're all a part of that it
just it makes me makes me feel like the
most recent conversations have been the
most profound for me and that's just the
part of I think the evolution of
consciousness and the flowering of a
flower as a human is just that these
ones that have been most recent are the
ones that are closest to the the deepest
parts of the evolution of my psyche and
so I'm biased to to talk about to talk
about them and just uh yeah and then
they pretty much have to do with the
theme of you know why are we here why
are we here what is this big thing
that's been created what's the purpose
of it why are we all embedded in it
where is it all going and how can we
identify what we're uniquely blueprinted
for and bring those gifts of the world
and how can we build a social fabric
that maximizes the potential of people
bringing those unique gifts forward and
that's I guess this big part of this who
I am that I'm trying to share with other
people and just disseminate content that
people have probably noticed that we've
had many like little shorter videos
happening on our channel like shorter a
couple minute videos around this exact
theme and eventually down the line
having other forms of content that's a
multimedia around this specific theme
itself so I'm glad that it's you know
definitely formed into this specific
ethos over the last couple years and I'm
just deeply grateful that people care
enough to watch and people care enough
to be guests on it and that that we have
the opportunity to to help transmit
something that is of value to people
that gets them more awakened and more
conscious and more aligned with their
deepest purpose and the plant in the
world so yeah thank you thank you how
did I'm actually curious how has this
changed you so do you do kind of have
you sensed that you've been changing
through this period I mean every you
know you have a record of the way you
see the world and you can recall it in
every episode yeah so how do you feel
that is it has changed you over time you
know from episode one where they're kind
of periods or points that you just
recall being extremely just transition
periods where you were not the same
inducing any moments like that that you
could recall I really like this question
yeah this is a really good one like
going back and thinking about all the
times that my consciousness has been
shifted to new ways of thinking that
have made it impossible to go back to
the old ways yeah those are some of my
favorite questions yeah I guess probably
one of my one of my favorite ones that's
that's happened quite recently is that
there there seems to be some sort of a
of a of a calling that we're all a part
of whether we're awake to it or not
whether we're just embedded in the
economic machinery or we're maybe a
little bit more awake and actually
asking this question of what we're all
building and why we're building it and
that's the question that's awakened me
probably the most recently is what are
we all building and a lot of it is
actually heard in the the question that
we started asking at the end of every
episode which is is Humanity of
biological bootloader for digital super
intelligence
and we are we're you know we're
approaching that time where it's it's
really about figuring out our own
spirituality our own ethics our own
morals our own deepest parts of our own
psyches and the collective purpose to
figure out what are we building and why
are we building it and we have to embed
these styles of thinking at the biggest
technology companies in the world the
biggest government's in the world the
biggest people that control so much of
the monetary supply and the and the
resource supply around the planet
because we're approaching a massive
intelligence revolution we talked about
it in our last episode with you about
computational Renaissance well if what's
about to happen is going to be building
digital super intelligences and we
already saw this with the United States
a great amount of of
uplifting people into newer standards of
living but also an extreme amount of
inequality that's created and if we
aren't careful about what we're building
and why we're building it and how to
democratize the fruits of the
revolutions that were going through so
that they can be in access to all people
to maximize everyone's prosperity that's
been such a profound shift for me like
you look and it's literally just looks
like on one side you have indigenous
people that are still interconnected to
their land to each other to the animals
plants to everything just still in
deeply interconnected and on the other
half the absolute other dichotomy to it
is us living in metropolis is completely
disconnected from the Stars completely
disconnected from each other even though
we live on top of each other we exchange
a sheet of paper for the Apple instead
of understanding that the Apple was
actually grown by the star and gives us
energy through the star and we that and
that aspect of disconnection to the
interconnect
is I believe the root of all of the
issues that we have a society so if
we're not going to look and implement
some of these very fundamental aspects
of interconnectedness in the future
building that we're going to it's gonna
be a disconnected separation focused
future rather than an interconnected
flourishing future that's the next world
that Ori and I are so passionate about
and we have people that work with us
brady angel we have so many other people
that have helped build what we're doing
Ron so many other people that have moved
this ball forward with us in that
specific direction all 600 of the guests
have moved us in that specific direction
my conscious is being shifted there is a
product of all of these other people
around us we stand on the shoulders of
giants and if we're not concerned about
that very big purpose about what we're
building and why we're building it and
children and adults aren't passionate
about that question then we're building
blindly and that's an issue
so I hear I hear you I have a question
and this is one that I struggled with
myself so your answer a man's I'm gonna
be answering it in my head as you answer
mm-hmm why do you care what makes you
responsible for the larger system why
why would you be responsible for it too
rather than just not be just do your own
thing what makes you feel this
incredible responsibility to help or to
drive the right decisions kind of what
is that inside and and where does that
come from well this is also an excellent
question there is no separation between
me you all the other humans all the
other plants animals there is no such
thing as separation and because of that
it's drove is drives me to want to make
sure that everything is going in the
highest possible direction and it's just
it's just
come something that's so true to my
nature that I can't even go away from it
every moment of my life is geared
towards that highest possible nature
that we can all be a part of there is no
separation it's all one big beautiful
one that's happening and we're all a
part of that one and I don't want I
don't want it to go into a less than
highest possible calling and so I
battled relentlessly every single day
for it to go to its high as possible
calling and that includes a lot of
really hard core protocol design it
requires architecting the future it's
not just some I'm gonna sit in a cave
and that's it
meditate on I am yeah it's not that it's
bringing your profound
interconnectedness to the matrix no in
shining the interconnectedness in the
fabric of the matrix to where the fabric
of the matrix becomes only
interconnected and that's it children
are born instead of saying you're
separate you're separate this Apple is
separate everything separate you're
separate from the air etc the water
it's your interconnected with the air
the water with each other
your words directly influence who I am
and what I become no and there's just no
other way to look at it besides it that
way and bringing the world closer and
closer to that truth of
interconnectedness of unity of oneness
it's just being an absolute martyr for
that future period I will die for that
future and I'm happy that it's finally
come to that there's nothing more than
that highest calling then upgrading
civilization to that highest calling
nothing else exists to me besides that
so you know that's that's that's a
really interesting perspective and I I
think that right now but you know you
could you always have to measure kind of
is this happening to us or are we doing
it right so a lot of people come to me
as a scientist and they go like you know
you guys are creating this AI and I'm
like then
I don't think you understand this is
happening to us and we're the only ones
trying to do it right but this is
something that's happening and now we
all need to figure it out but you got a
all contribute right so so you're
contributing what do you get for it what
have you gotten forward so far
contribution yeah the last answer just
was yeah it's getting awakening all this
you've been doing what have you received
and what have you lost as a result I
know I lost the wife and her relations
yeah this is you know this is very very
serious question yeah this is a very
serious question how much do you care
about what you're talking about
yeah because many people talk about talk
big games and they're not willing to
sacrifice going to the bar that's like
the war that's like the most simple one
to sacrifice they're not willing to
sacrifice watching sports as games
they're not willing to sacrifice video
games
they're not willing to sacrifice these
are getting a little harder sacrifice
time with friends sacrifice a girlfriend
or a wife or a husband or a boyfriend
I'm not willing to sacrifice
Nizar this becomes just become strange
here because at some point if you're
also not exercising eating healthy and
not really being enough contributing
you're not contributing any right you're
you're you're actually taking all of the
potential that you could be contributing
and you're sacrificing it because you
think you're being smart in sleeping for
hours now when you're literally not able
to press the save button as much on the
data that you are trying to store from
the previous day and you're not as ready
for the data that you're about to take
in that next day because you just didn't
sleep that well so there's like this
there's there's there's some sort of a
like of equilibrium there's an
equilibrium of sorts here where you got
a drop of the mundane [ __ ] and hyper
focus on what your blooper
for in parce for the right signals in
the world and that includes people but
also understand that you're only gonna
have so much time to ask your mom and
dad questions about who your family is
and where you came from and you're only
gonna have so much time to to to
understand what love is and to dive into
that beautiful relationship of love with
another human at that like solely a
little twin flame level and so you know
you're you're only gonna have so much
time that you can go out and and like
literally hug a tree mm-hmm and go
through the process of literally hugging
that tree and making sweet love to
nature oh sweet sweet love and I mean
laying there and letting the bird chirps
just penetrate your spirit yeah and
knowing what that feels like and not in
some sort of like a way that is around
the I'm watching this video on YouTube
of this bird chirping ya know but so so
I just came from the redwood forest and
I spoke to some of those trees man
there's an ancient wisdom inside of them
this kind of silence this deep old
ancient silence that you can only
understand and appreciate once you
actually spend time with these things
you know slice like it's it's these are
living organisms that have a lot of
stuff a lot of history a lot of stories
they've seen a lot yes Wow the lineages
from them for the longest time and um
you also asked about what is to gain
from this and what you gain from it is
you gain an unprecedented level of
waking up every single morning with the
fire under your ass
yeah purpose meaning period yes no I
like people so I have this little
podcast I'm kind of working on a little
bit it's called the speed of freedom
it's actually about kind of going
forward and and leaving all of your
fears behind and just pursuing your
passions and that's what I've always
respected you because you actually
pursue your passions and you fight your
fears you know you you kind of hurdle
over them and and over time I think what
I've been observing as a kind of you
know observer that people people have so
much potential that that they could
really be releasing and they're always
wished they self restrict themselves
they they stop themselves from achieving
their dreams and their goals and it
takes very small kind of conversations
or small things to push them over I'm
all about that and one of the things
that I find that intelligent people do
actually is to explore a territory or a
question before everybody else does at
risk to themselves they sail out
Columbus and Magellan and all these
explorers they sail out into this dark
deep ocean and here a floor yeah and
they might not come back but if they do
they have answers that others are too
afraid to go out and understand so what
I love about that is and I guess for you
kind of what I'm picking up on is you
have a deep ecosystem intelligence right
knowing where you are in the ecosystem
is very important and knowing your place
and role in that ecosystem and how it
you interact with it is a is a form of
intelligence or a form of just yeah it's
like your place in nature yeah to
appreciate that is to be I guess
completed in some ways to be in the
right forest or the right you know under
the right tree yeah that's that's a
great way to put it so if you're a big
puzzle piece in this oneness how do you
fit into the one this what are you
uniquely blueprinted for and then how do
you figure that out about yourself
and then how do you surround yourself
with the right people and processes that
get you to express that unique thing
that you're blueprinted for at its
maximum potential and you have to go on
these hero's journeys it's just a part
of it you enter into the unknown into
areas that are literally at the expense
of all these other things that you want
to do
all this other stuff and you and when
you come back from this deep exploration
into the unknown you have incredible
fruits to share with the people that are
your your family your friends your
community the world and so and to
actually know how to do that sharing
process is just this important answer no
we're never go into those woods you come
back you might have something to say but
you might not have though the words to
explain it I mean it's it's I find
people that that struggle to explain
something really challenging that just
means that Wow they've seen something
profound that they can't actually
express there's no words designed yet to
to explore that territory and so they
must find words they must create words
you know and and then build to a
reveries right these these complex
multi-dimensional visualizations and
expelling dreams and share them with
people it takes time to craft of these
things to in order to share them and I I
think it's really cool because I love
this point this is a really important
point you have to when you go when you
come back from going on to this big
journey that you you sometimes you have
to make new words a neologism sometimes
you have to if did you have to like we
talked about in the last episode you
have to structure these profound
realizations in ways that make it
relatable for other people to understand
them and it requires a whole again a
shift in consciousness a transformation
in your own consciousness to be able to
know how to share these stories and how
to tell these stories just look at all
of the best storytellers that have ever
existed and try and find the best
principals from what they did and also
bring in new principals that they've
never thought of and share stories in
that way and it'll transform other
people that that consume those stories
and so this is a big part of what I have
to do I have all these people that have
been teaching us things and now it's
like how do you take what all these
people have been teaching you and how do
you find the most first principled
understanding of what all of them have
been teaching you and then share that
with the world the society is missing a
most first principle cannon
why we're here who we are where we're
going missing it clearly missing it it's
the most missing piece of our fabric of
existence and I've taken on the burden
of wanting to bring that into the world
the privilege of wanting to bring that
into the world now and it requires
having the people around me that also
helped me become the most conscious the
most aware the most pure the most
resilient in that process because this
is not some sort of an individualistic
thing this is a very non separation
interconnected thing to endeavor into
doing I love it I'm obsessed with it
yeah storytelling is everything when you
kind of expected now like I expected
from people now like I expect
originality and it's almost like if
you're mediocre or if you're like
leaning towards that mediocre middle
like I almost can't I don't even I
already know that so I don't want to
kind of spend my valuable time doing
something that I already understand very
well I want original ideas and subjects
and if somebody's explored something
that's sort of like the only way you
could really get my attention it's not
by saying something that I'm already
familiar with so yeah that kind of do
you think some people have a more of a
tilt towards originality versus I guess
mediocrity you know and and what do the
people as long as you want to be in one
of those that's fine but do you do you
ever find in your conversations or in
your experience that some people are
living in mediocrity but want to kind of
explore these areas and and struggle and
what have you done to kind of push them
this is also very interesting there's an
analogy that I think works really well
for this and it's that all of us are
colors on a color wheel so even if you
want to be the color orange that goes
and brings some sort of a profound
awareness transformation to the planet
that impacts a billion people you can be
the color orange if you want to be the
color blue and maybe you just want to
have a child with with a partner and you
want to raise that child
yeah that's the color blue maybe you
want to be green and you want to target
don't get in yellows way orange in this
case yeah yeah don't get in yeah greens
already there you know yeah yeah so this
is you know these are this is a really
interesting way of looking at it like in
in a sense I don't even like who's
saying that people's blueprints are for
mediocrity or amateurism or whatever or
excellence or whatever more so just um
just like whatever you're uniquely
blueprinted for it is just your own
unique blueprint in your own unique
contribution that you're bringing in the
interconnected collective that's moving
forward and to actually respect that
uniqueness about yourself and like
certain people are just gonna bring more
transformation to the world and certain
people are gonna bring the
transformation in a different way that
you may not actually see for a long time
down the line like we had this on
another recent episode just like um with
actually Charles Eisenstein he just
brought up that you know you never know
that a mom raising a child with a very
complicated neurodiverse personality may
do an excellent job at that process and
then only after that neurodiverse child
grows up to find their blueprint and go
into the world because their mom did
such a good job that then that child
maybe three generations down the line
actually has one of the most profound
impacts on the world their children and
their lineage too just because of the
way that that mom engaged with the child
so you never actually know it's also
butterfly affected around the world and
then so deeply interconnected that you
never actually know so just think of
yourself as a unique color a unique
instrument that's being played in the
collective symphony of awakening of
becoming more alive as this creation
erupts and gets constructed more and
more and just find your puzzle piece in
it you're what you're uniquely
blueprinted for and love that about your
stuff and what you're doing here and
don't ever let the
especially the age of of follower counts
and likes and subscribers and all that
type of stuff that drives anxiety and
mental torment and stuff like that like
be content with your exact role and
don't let those things get to you you
know
can you feel compersion can you feel joy
when someone else experiences joy when
someone is saying that they've made some
profound impact on the world is it that
you have envy or is it that you have joy
for them can you can you repattern your
behaviors to have joy for when other
people feel joy and to not have envy
when other people achieve something and
then you're growing the pie and
everybody is more about the growth of
the pie in the way that the growth of
the pie is enabling a distribution of
fruits as well as long as the fabric is
implemented in a way that enables the
distribution of the fruits rather than
feeling like oh Tristan has this many
things and I only have this many things
we got to get that out of here and we
have to focus more on not buying a
seventh yacht and a seventh watch and a
seventh house but instead of really
thinking about what if I gave thirty
artists and entrepreneurs and spiritual
leaders around the world $1,000 each
with my thirty thousand dollars what if
I did that what kind of butterfly effect
with that half as an experiment these
are experiments human games you could
always kind of find new experiments to
play with I have actually was thinking
about an interesting question I would
love to ask you in particular do you
think technology is inherently unfair
it just frequently seems like it all
comes down to the distribution of it
always like if you're so interconnected
with everyone else all the [ __ ] time
then you know that when a person
discovers something a new technology
that it's never about that person
discovering them it's about literally
the one the collective discovering it
and when you feel that way about it it
transforms the way that that technology
becomes oh my god I need off the IP I
own all of this to a how do we
democratize the fruits of this around
the world as effectively as possible
because we are all one all of us deserve
access to this technology
so I is the most important one out of
all of those period as you build super
intelligence can you democratize the
fruits of it around the world so I have
this kind of fear a little bit that kind
of it you know I always look at fast
food as a context and so I imagine that
you know people that have to mention
Goodman theta metabolism and good
heuristics for deciding on what
information they're gonna use versus not
use and be very selective essentially
some people are gonna be have a data
diet of fast food cheap frills right
cheap neurons activated and some are
gonna go for high-quality meals you know
that kind of really satisfy and our
tastes you know in different ways and
there are unique colors colors yeah the
idea is some people will choose the fast
food while some decide to use this kind
of high quality brand or like eat steaks
at a you know restaurant it's not about
money it's about actually decision or
selection for a specific approach there
it's you know it's the approach that
they take so my question is with
technology what if with AI for example
why what do you think that some people
will always select the
the AI with the information or the data
that is unclean because it's cheaper or
because it's you know simpler to
understand whereas the people that
really want to accelerate and create
this atmosphere of just knowledge will
choose the highly selective ones and
might have to basically I'm worried that
there will be four AIS and some will be
for the people that appreciate data
quality and are intelligent enough to
actually select them and there's those
are going to be subject to human bias
and the cheaper ones that I guess the
vast majority of society will adopt as
fast food AI I mean do you see that kind
of happening or something that we should
be concerned with and potentially even
um you know a proactive about preventing
another interesting question when you
play along with the color wheel analogy
a little bit further it kind of takes
you into an understanding that are there
actually manipulations that are
happening to people's psyches where
they're actually not able to pursue what
they're blueprinted for is the social
fabric around us just pushing people as
unique shapes into the same circular
stamps in the machinery and not being
able to creatively express themselves
and so when that is is addressed it it
makes it so that every person is able to
uniquely express themselves free from
for when you say like is somebody going
to approach a fast-food style of an
input stream that they're taking in all
of the time the answer is that's a
unique color on the color wheel but do
people know that there are other options
that's always the question
and where does cognitive ease play into
effect because if I can just you know
just realistically speaking it is
literally like just take give me the
instant dopamine you don't be that
feeling of mean numbing myself away from
my blueprint away from my fullest
potential in the world
and I feel it all the time you can feel
it kind of when you're starting to enter
into some of the the this you you notice
only an hour or four hours later once
you've been on that porn site or once
you've been on that that that Netflix or
once yeah once you've been on YouTube or
whatever it is Facebook and Sandra
Twitter that you're just you just being
just you're not actually pursuing what
you're uniquely blueprinted for as much
as you're being fed something that's
causing you to fit into a different
color than maybe what you're uniquely
here for so when you're talking about
this I I'm I'm all I'm all about this
how do you have a unit like a bell curve
of people to move from a place of a
feeling like their uniqueness is not
being expressed and how do you help move
them into a place into a social fabric
where they can express it and I love
that and you can leverage AI to do that
AI can also be leveraged for serious
malevolence it all goes back to the same
thing okay nice it's an intention even
prior to intention is who are you how
awake are you how interconnected are you
how much do you have a unique communion
with all that is because if you don't
have those things in place I'm gonna
think that you're different than me I'm
gonna want to self deal my own self more
money to buy another yacht
instead of literally realize that you're
a divine unique human that has a unique
blueprint of an artistic expression into
the world that I want to help build
something to catalyze exactly that if we
don't have that awakened shift big
problems happen big bifurcations happen
in the in the trajectory of civilization
when people think that there can
different from other people it's not
that it's not that everyone it's not
like this hole so it's hoping it's not
this whole postmodern I like super like
social justice e style of putting it
this is not political whatsoever this is
strictly spiritual and scientific not
political
spiritual and scientific we all come
from one we all come I don't care if you
call it the Big Bang if you call it
source if you call all that it is God
creation infinite consciousness I don't
give a [ __ ] what you call it we all come
from one and if you begin to view it
that way all of a sudden then I don't
have malevolence towards you or anyone
else right but do I want to help build a
social fabric that makes it so that
people can't actually that can awaken
faster and that we can't have someone
else killing someone because they
weren't awake enough to realize that yes
that's the point of architecting that
future that next world mm-hmm
so and and so that one I mean I guess
the way I interpret the you know when I
think about it
I've been having this deep intuition
recently that the Sun is the source of
consciousness like a raw form of
consciousness that is basically
radiating on the earth and then we
create concentrations of that
consciousness and act it out but I guess
the source of it is the Sun so you got
me with yeah I mean the Sun is the one
in my opinion but you know that's just
kind of like a artistic go pro yeah
there's a there's a way to viewing it in
terms of like sub logos there's a sub
logos that is our star and then there's
even above that is a different logos
which is the locus of the actual galaxy
and then past that logos as the locus of
the one the logos of the one and just
you know as someone that's
scientifically oriented you know that it
all goes back to one source know the
only thing that I kind of feel that way
that it all goes back to one source so
how could it be to explain how it could
not be so right it goes back to one
source but that ecosystem intelligence
require to feel like one right to
essentially challenge your personal kind
of just challenge your emotions and to
engage your brain and your consciousness
or you know kind of like on a deeper
level you you
challenge that so I have this intuitive
or instinctive feeling that I have kind
of you know it could be aggression it
could be whatever but at the same time I
have this secondary layer that I applied
to it was just like yeah but you know
this is for the better good or this is
this way and reconcile these
contradictions and I find that a lot of
people have these internal
contradictions so so regarding to I
think it is a single source that we all
come from genetically and obviously in
other way life formed and I think we're
all powered by the same energy sources
this collective consciousness or
intelligence that people talk about I
think they they borrow scientific ideas
and sometimes not rigorously so I would
encourage them to try harder to you know
don't fit the quantum circle in the
spiritual square you know because it
models the language I think we should be
very careful with language and that's
why the one for me I think it's um it is
easy to misinterpret or to misuse and
that's why I well you know that so
that's kind of my resistance to the one
then stop then stop stop the
misinterpretation process yeah stop the
misusing process stop the over dogmatism
of that clear communication just clearly
our communication sciences spirituality
are two sides of the same coin now you
will not be able to advance civilization
in the most prosperous way possible if
you don't marry the two they have to be
married there's no other way forward
that maximizes prosperity than the two
getting married and actually the
marriage of the two has a very big
overlap with what's happening in quantum
mechanics they have a very big overlap
with what's happening with consciousness
they have a huge overlap in those fields
but to be able to sign you science in
the actual scientific method to
rigorously probe into what is true
spiritually speaking and not what is
just a myriad of theories sigh
spirituality both have the same issue in
that case so when they just have a
shitload of things that are false about
what they're trying to propagate at the
same time falsehoods in science
falsehoods and spirituality find the
truth and be more and more and more
resilient and honored around only having
the truth be shined on both of those
sides of the coin and you can maximize
prosperity so I kind of feel like
science is the new religion and and I'm
gonna justify that by saying you know I
think religion is the way I see them as
people see them as beliefs unless if I
actually see them as hard drives
civilizational hard drives it's the it's
it's a emergent property of civilization
to record history and record stories and
and record lessons that can be
broadcasted so it's it's an ancient
social media religion is ancient social
media it records history and stories
without it we would basically don't have
a hard drive for civilization and now we
actually have a hard drive for
civilization and and modern social
networks are actually kind of taking
that role of like recording what happens
so the idea is as an anthropologist
right I would love to know what happened
in ancient Rome how they thought how
they imagined if if there was a single
thing that I could get from Rome that
would give me an interpretation of what
it was or ancient Greece if they had a
social network that would be all I would
ever need to understand their
civilization at the time it's a record
it's a recorder it's a it's a device for
recordings human civilization and
stories and I think science has now
become this the new religion because
religions were responsible for that
there was no other medium that did that
it's a collective sort of machine that
everybody deployed and and it it created
the incentives to record and to catalog
and and to put so much energy and effort
into understanding the stories and
recording the truths and I find it funny
that you know all of these spiritual
leaders Mohammed and Jesus and they all
underwent this incredible
a spiritual journey and literally for
thousands of years we've been
remembering trying to remember that
feeling that they got that that that
experience that they got the vision the
clarity that they got literally entire
civilizations were built upon
remembering how to get back there
whether it's a you know a siddhartha
gautama or jesus like it it's incredible
that we even in architected entire
civilizations just to remember how they
achieved enlightenment that's it that's
it's a recording device if we don't
marry science and spirit we will have
more scientists that have never actually
felt the interconnectedness of
everything
building the artificial intelligences
and the other things that we actually
don't want people that have never felt
interconnected to build this is the
thing I don't care what religion you
look at thing that all point to the same
transcendent trance psychological
feeling of being interconnected with
everything with communing with the
infinite and when you do that you become
a better scientist those two things have
to marry and spiritualists understanding
fundamental science is also extremely
important moving forward
period you know there's no separation of
the two but I can't separate the two
sides of the same coin
but I found that a lot of these data
scientists and artificial intelligence
experts I mean they are really attuned
with themselves and self actualized and
spiritual I mean they for the most part
they've been you know we're very lucky
that AI is being kind of discovered by
these people of all people what we're
very fortunate I have no idea who you're
talking about that is a spiritual leader
that is building AI because I meaning
scientists scientists okay that are
spiritual rather than so so this so I've
found that scientists and AI experts and
data scientists in my experience have
been very
just intelligent enough to have a broad
scope of things so they don't leave out
spirituality as far as I've seen they're
not kind of automata robots I've
actually seen a lot of really deep
analysis done for social so what I'm
saying is I'll agree with you that
there's some of that yeah but I still
feel like there is way way more people
that are unconsciously building advances
in science that then they wonder well
why is there will that equality well
because you'd literally didn't program
with the first principled understanding
of our world what you wanted the future
to be like they do yourself not
experiencing interconnectedness and only
this is what I fear intellectually
masturbating around what
interconnectedness is is exactly the
reason why some of these people will
come up and say that oh yeah I know
transpersonal psychology I know
communion with God and then they'll go
and malevolently they won't even think
twice about the inequality that they're
that they may make they won't think
twice about the way that will destroy
our natural ecosystems that we live in
with what they built it no longer
matters the supply chain that I get this
device in if I don't give a [ __ ] about
the interconnectedness of everything if
I only care about the use of the
computational capacities that the device
gives me in order to build the AI
then I've lost complete understanding of
the interconnectedness of all of the
resources that were used in order to put
the device together that gives me the
computational capacity so this is a very
first principle thing every single
person that's building the future needs
to have feelings of deep
interconnectedness prior to actually
building it otherwise you'll have a
bunch of other symptoms happen the route
is interconnectedness the route is
interconnectedness yeah you know I I
mean I fundamentally agree with that and
job my experience in my conversations I
I've kind of penetrated you know the
scientific soul and I've seen a
significant amount of responsibility
there um there's a reason why this stuff
is you know hasn't gone rogue yet and
that's because there's incredible people
kind of managing and making sure but I
think as this technology becomes
democratized and anybody could build a
super virus or a super AI like going
forward or you know a network this
engineered for a specific outcome I
don't think this has happened already
just just look at what the look at what
social networks are right now you know I
think there's just a I think the people
that built them you know sorry to some
of them but I just think that they
lacked interconnected feelings because
if they did they want to prioritize the
attention economy and the money oriented
business plans of that paradigm in order
to build it they would have thought more
from a first principle perspective I may
didn't so in this area I feel like they
saw what they could see at the time with
20/20 vision today now you could see the
byproducts and outcomes and that's kind
of like it's always important to
remember that what it looked like from
there then exact very different from
what it looks like about now
absolutely on these lines transform like
morph over its it's true when you when
you look now it's always 20/20 vision
about how the social network should have
been created or why did we even make
nuclear weapons in the face actually
still still it holds true if humans are
really deeply interconnected to each
other to God to nature to everything
around them to all that is if they are
they won't build nuclear weapons they
won't have ego around this as mine
that's yours they don't have malevolence
around money-oriented attention economy
oriented business plans on social
networks all of these problems are
solved from a first principle of
interconnectedness I don't think I don't
think the CEOs of these big companies
around the world or the the plutocrats
the ones that are trying to govern
people that are the wealthiest around
the world have
actually had feelings of
interconnectedness if they don't have
feelings of awakening and
interconnectedness we are destined for a
disastrous future yeah but a lot of them
are getting it now
a lot of them are getting it so you know
how what do you have Marc Benioff who
else no no no well really who else do
you have so so I I attend the Chinese
government and the US government II of
the deep state or the people that
actually own all of the monetary systems
around the world do you have them that
are feeling deep states of
interconnectedness do you have the
people that are funding wars with
weapons do you have them having deep
feelings of interconnectedness because
we don't all of the indigenous elders
around the world are all pointing to the
same thing right now which is you as a
younger brother we as younger brother
that has moved into the metropolis and
wanted to build build build create
engineer engineer tinker have completely
forgotten what the older brother knows
which is the deep interconnectedness
that we have and that's why we have so
many of the disasters that we have
around the world so the biggest root to
all of our issues you know III think so
I think there's a I kind of look at it
as we are just evolving and evolution is
hard as a species and you know the
things the the the were the tools that
we had before weren't good enough for us
to really build robust systems and maybe
they're just maybe there was a
leadership people didn't know people
were innocent people were stupid
whatever it I think you know whatever
happened in the past I'm sort of I've
learned to think locally and like act
locally and think globally I guess it
all works too and really for me it's so
what can I influence in my immediate
backyard and these plutocrats you know I
speak to a lot of them and they're sweet
sweet people I really just want to make
that point that Siri I'm serious like
honestly they're good people why don't
you name a couple plutocrats that are
good people well yeah look people that
are trying to control
other people are not good people
yeah I you know country I don't know if
they're trying to control I'm seeing
they're trying to influence what wait
from what first principal are they
trying to influence they're trying to
make money I get it
wait ago how is it it's not good it's
not good it's not good but I think that
they weren't given mental models or
provided though oh wait and then they're
the ones that are trying to build the
governments of the future even better
you know they're the actual e has had a
lot of stress over this because they
actually don't know and so do their kids
because they have made a disaster they
uh they've they've under the disguise
that they've created some sort of a
profound value for civilization when out
of the several thousand billionaires
that are on the planet that only a very
small fraction of them have actually
provided a true spiritual interconnected
value for the world and the other ones
are propagating some disastrous meme and
disastrous protocols of economic
machinery that are among us and then
they're now also trying to defend
themselves by reshaping rules and
regulations in their own favors through
being plutocrats i think it's all
burning people it's hard to manage
governments I think it's genuinely hard
and I think mistakes were made but I
think it's actually hard and it's not
always crystal layer let's give crystal
clear examples ok yeah ok if you want to
bring some sort of value to the world
and you want to make money in the
process
go through a deep period of
interconnected feelings that are
transpersonal doesn't realize yourself
readily it is not a privilege it is a
first inner it's an inner but it's it
used to be a privilege now it's become
accessible but I think that it's it you
know a serious look up yeah this
regularly this is great yes I'm actually
saying
you know if if it's sick time period
it's like different generations if they
didn't know there was another option and
so they just did whatever what was done
at the time to succeed but now I'm see
I'm literally see I go to these things
that where I meet these people and
they're actually innocently trying to do
better they might not know how but
they're actually trying they want to do
better their actions are not reflective
but they want to do good and I think
it's just they're powerless to even
transform or change themselves seriously
you know I actually sure said I think I
think I think you have a very a true
understanding of a very small percentage
of people that are the ones that are
around maybe yeah and I think that I
think the rest that are have been talked
about by so many of the other leaders
that are critiquing the the fabric of
separation that we all live in are the
ones that are being extremely clear
about the it's just it's beyond my legal
approach so if I want to be it's it's
it's this reality is exactly the way it
is supposed to be right now yeah because
when you're that this is why it's such
an exciting creation that we're all a
part of because it's not a [ __ ]
utopia that there are so many disastrous
things that are happening especially the
most first principled one which is the
root of separation that then are
catalyzing all the other symptom issues
that make it fun for us to have to raise
to this big challenge and go and solve
that most first principled issue of are
the feelings of separation that then
solve all the others down the line
symptom level issues this is the funnest
game this is the funnest game look but
to be completely truthful about your
about intentions and even prior to
intentions as feelings of
interconnectedness let's take a poll out
of I believe the numbers about 1,500
billionaires right now out of them how
many of them have ever experienced ego
death how
how many of them have ever had trans
personal feelings how many of them have
ever felt interconnected to other humans
their ecosystems around them to nature
to plants and animals to the air that
they breathe to the water they drink to
the food that they eat how many of them
have truly right this is a very
subjective feeling that you have to try
and quantify but how many of them have
and there are more and more people
around the world shout out to some of
our friends at places like quality
Research Institute that are doing these
things that are scientific experiments
of things like the symmetry theory of
valence if you can map using EEG fMRI
people's brain states that are literally
showing you that they have deep feelings
of interconnectedness you could then go
and put that of that array and that
analysis technique on the 1500
billionaires and go and see how many of
them have ever had feelings of
interconnectedness or not or if they
know how to get to those feelings of
interconnectedness or not and my
hypothesis from a feeling is that it's
90 percent of them have never had that
feeling or maybe have when they've had a
child they have a child and they go oh
my god profound feelings of
interconnectedness and then they go back
to some sort of extractive manipulative
process again well I mean look you know
III I'm actually fortunate enough to to
be able to influence these people and a
lot of people a lot of other people but
but the wealthy ones the billionaires
there's just human they're not really
any they're not special they just have a
lot of resources and however they got
them volt channeling through them this
purposefully maybe that makes the
experiment what it is this game yes
maybe but but I think what's important
right now is to actually go in and find
those people and help educate them on
how they could contribute and that's it
like that's just a practical
anthropological approach and believe me
I honestly believe that they would be
happy to contribute if they knew how so
it's about us creating clear
instructions on what would be the best
for them
so you actually have to create games
that they win in and you can do that if
you understand the symphony of
incentives you could actually improve
their game theory and keep them happy
you know so it's it's it's like you can
build stuff that has everybody
collaborate and work together what the
fact that they've had fortunes and that
they got them in a certain way I mean
that's that's tens of thousands of years
of history that that's exactly what's
happened in history and only now can we
actually go in a different direction and
attempt to do it the right way you can
actually make a fortune today by the way
you could become a billionaire today in
this way if you create medicine and cure
cancer you cure cancer you're gonna
become billionaire tomorrow and like you
can actually do good and make money
today so what I'm saying is with all
these billionaires like I don't know if
they're the appropriate category to
target I think that just generationally
we've had different education systems
and different incentive structures and
the one that exists now gives us the
opportunity to fix a lot of the problems
that were in the past and that's what we
and we should be grateful that it
happened and push forward and and just
kind of try as hard as we can to
influence these people and believe me
they're just as human as you are and and
they they want love and all this things
I actually they're actually even all
they're all too human that's actually
the thing that sometimes you expect
stuff from billionaires that they don't
have and you're like wait a minute but
you have a billion dollars and you don't
have these what's the path to maximum
flourishing that's the big question
because if you go and try and go to the
influencers of the world and the
billionaires of the world and you try
and go directly to them and go and hey
we want you to have feelings of
interconnectedness we're gonna try and
catalyze these feelings of
interconnectedness for you so that we
can all prosper abundantly more
effectively together is that the best
approach that's probably one of many
good approaches there's lots of other
really good approaches at a grassroots
level that cause
awakening among collective that then go
into the inclusive stake holding fabrics
of the future the new architectures and
designs and protocols that then we build
our future on top of I love looking at
it both ways but I'm still extremely you
don't you don't get into this problem
and then just have no nothing to blame
the blame is not on billionaires the
blame is on the root of separation that
we have felt over the last period of
time that has caused us to create these
problems I am no longer trying to sell
you something because I care about your
inclusive fitness but because I want to
take money from you no that's this big
first principle change the money pole
value system I think that's more
important that's what how do you get to
the highest how do you get to the
highest possible possibility of an
enlightened civilization how do you get
there it's a root issue the feelings of
separation how do you catalyze feelings
of interconnectedness for people around
the world as fast as possible and as
safely and as gently as strategically as
skillfully as possible use their
networks catalyze those feelings of
interconnectedness for all you use use
these new social networking technologies
so one of the things I worry about is
that these ancient networks ruined the
concept of social networks for everybody
they kind of they started off the gate
with anti social networks they label
them as social networks and now
everybody is like oh hi you see they're
all bad and the worst part is that you
could actually create beautiful networks
that to bring people together for a
myriad of reasons whether you love
rollerblading or bicycling or podcasting
a passion networks right so but people
are afraid of these social instruments
now so I just think it's hey if it's
broken from before make it better fix it
and
and you'll get the credit for it and
you'll actually just be able to
influence and improve a lot of people's
lives
shouldn't you love what you do I'll
compete them I'll compete you love what
you're doing yet it's still one layer
past the feelings of interconnectedness
you you want to bring people you're
bringing people closer to each other for
more feelings of interconnectedness
concentrating consciousness on given
focuses which is beautiful
yet there's something that's so deeply
first principle that is at lack even in
the first place in figuring out the most
again skillful way to enlighten people
around the world in a non dogmatic way
you know way treat them with love this
is in what way with it treat them treat
them like people I mean it's very simple
like like I don't really care if people
are not intelligent or have certain
limitations I treat everybody like a
human being I don't have time for
everybody considering you know that I
have kind of practical goals and stuff
but it's like treating everybody with
that is conscious with respect and yeah
I guess that's one of the ways that it's
it's best to get there but in any case
that's great that's a great first
principle yeah but you feel that in your
heart or is it truly in that you learn
that IOU yourself and me learning it
over time yes but saying these words you
can look at someone in the eyes and they
can say I have love for everyone and
then deep down they don't know what that
feels like they've never felt that
they're playing a game and that's very
important to be strategically aware of
that will look right at the devil in the
eyes and they will say I love feelings
of interconnectedness and then later on
they will [ __ ] destroy something for
money and and keep it under and keep it
under the radar so it's not it's much
harder to do that today honestly like
there's so Marron societies and and and
so I think that last questions and yeah
rap yeah okay so I think I like how we
got to this no dude I mean it's a very
critical important area to explore those
first principles I'm always driving
conversation here and and the idea is
you know blaming somebody
[Music]
maybe but I just feel they weren't
blaming anyway we were blaming the roots
of spilling zuv separation right that's
it yeah so I just think that's all part
of the game I'm excited about now
there's an opportunity to connect people
through all these different approaches
and that's the one that like honestly I
don't have time at this anymore I spent
a lot of time stressing and being angry
about it
now I kind of just I only have time to
help and connect people and love and I
just don't
I forgot how to hate and in a certain
way really like it's there's you can
actually forget and and I just I think
that that's what everybody should try to
do if they can if they're fortunate
enough to have the time to look inside
mmm that's really yeah you know people
have made mistakes but again as I
mentioned in the previous podcast it I
actually really there's kind of like a
line a point where whatever you've done
in the past I actually say [ __ ] it it
doesn't matter it only matters which you
do going forward that's the only thing
I'm measuring and then if you if you
[ __ ] it up yeah we'll get you but
otherwise anything you've done before
man like it's an uncertain world and
it's really hard to know what you need
to do what's the right thing to do today
I think as we're defining what's the
clearest path forward now we could
really measure who's deviating from a
truly agreed-upon perspective and
direction and I think we haven't agreed
yeah I don't think people like us have
even done the necessary we haven't
finished agreeing on where we're going
to be cutting people off for not getting
there that's what I'm saying that way we
haven't actually succeeded yet in
outlining a future path that's worth the
going towards in order to punish anyone
we haven't set the game rules yet and I
think now we have the tools and
technologies and the people and the
responsible parties to set the proper
game rules and going forward I think we
can start holding people accountable but
only after everybody's been given the
same set of rules and I think that the
one set of rules like the what you know
I think that is kind of a practical
approach to this so you know that's
that's kind of I I just I used to be a
very angry and now I I find love and
passion and and humor and I try to do
humility as much as I can as much as
possible because that's for me it's not
for them it's not for you it's for me
it's selfish it's a selfish thing to be
in love and to feel passion and explore
the world it's selfish to love somebody
else
you know because it's actually hard and
and but but anyway so so that's kind of
where I see money systems all that stuff
I'm sure it's broken it's very broken
and it's never helped me to be honest
with you I'm you know but but going
forward I think we have a chance to make
it right and we got to do it with as
much attention to detail as possible so
I invite you to collaborate with me on
doing that and bringing everybody that's
share this that shares this intention
together and I'm I'm pretty sure we
could collectively do a lot more and
just out-compete them I'll compete them
with logic and order and and structure
and beauty so never forget the first
principle we are all interconnected
yeah even feelings of separation are the
ones that have caused all of the
symptoms that we have in our reality and
thank you for driving conversation in
this podcast towards who we are what we
care about what we've become where we're
all going it's very important for people
that view the program to know more about
who we are in that sense and also it's
important for people that view this on
your podcast as well this will be on
Tristan's podcast as well for those that
are viewing or listening on that
platform this is what we are here over
at simulation and what we care about so
these are important conversations join
us across platforms
and these are some of the most important
conversations that society needs to be
having and it helps having someone else
take the role of the interlocutor in the
dialectic and because then new things
can flower yeah and I really appreciate
you wanting to have me on and do that
dude and it's always about growth and
and just kind of reaching higher for
yourself and again think like act
locally think globally the
responsibility for the world is is ours
together but it's not yours alone and
that's where there's a lot of kind of
peace that comes from knowing that
you're doing good and you do good
locally and that's like that is the
measurement of true class and spirit so
I've seen what you've been doing and
that's actually a very impressive like
how much people you've brought together
and shared ideas so and that's kind of
for everybody just to act locally and
hope that your actions manifest and
emerge into you know emergent properties
globally and and that's what we're
starting to experience as a species and
you know that that comes from somewhere
so from that one one place uh-huh I love
you so much thank you awesome brother
thank you so much for this conversation
and and this was the simulation episode
what something around six something or
other
around 600 thank you guys so much and
we're out Cheers
yeah let us know your thoughts would
love to hear people's thoughts in the
comments on this one this was a really
good one
thanks for manifesting integers thank
you thank you thank you guys everyone
Cheers